each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
it's my pleasure to introduce my quads
he's currently at Yahoo researcher and I
think he had been to many prestigious
institutions also besides yahoo he had
been a professor at the Harvard
University then he went to Stanford and
then Berkeley and then find him to yahoo
and today will present us about
something about open source thank you so
let me start out with a bunch of
disclaimers ah so disclaimer number one
the title of this paper is misleading it
probably should have been called open
source a solution to hold up problems
half a century of public software
institutions I am not the other way
around ah and this is the way we will
present this paper so start with the
second line and then I will continue
with the first line and start talking
about the history that actually
illustrates how open source solves a
holdup problem but first I'll have to
explain about the holdup problem so
rationally anticipate that even though
serve the the second part the history
part is something like seventy percent
of the paper and its really interesting
history i really recommend reading it
because it's something like 15 pages and
it's a lot of fun never let us i
anticipate that i will probably spend
eighty percent of my time on this part
and i will probably end up completely
running out of time and spending about
three minutes on this part but hopefully
the first part would be sufficiently
intriguing that they would actually want
to read about the history of open source
so the other disclaimer I is that I am
normally not a nervous presenter but
this time I am because I'm talking about
something I know virtually nothing about
to a group of people who know about this
something tremendously more than I do so
I'm an economist I'm an economic
theorist I prove theorems about auctions
about matching about market design and I
also design
our kids were hundreds of millions and
billions of dollars actually transact so
that's my day job studying markets and
actually designing them in practice ah
my job has nothing to do with software
and I know we're a little about it says
this paper is very much kind of a hot
beer kind of exercise out of curiosity
and relay here I'm talking about
something I don't know much about so the
disclaimers and order this paper is very
unusual paper for me it has no formulas
no theorems none of that nature so I'm
just knitting not sure so finally um
another important disclaimer so
obviously you probably know that yahoo
uses open-source quite heavily and also
contributes to open source quite heavily
and none of the views impressed on the
expressed in this paper have absolutely
anything to do with the views of my
employer and also i don't have any
inside scoop on the off on yahoo
strategy visibly open source so all the
opinions are entirely my own I am those
of my quarter yuri at active who is a
PhD student in the school of information
at berkeley he's primarily sociologist
he's also an occasional open-source
programmer so with all those disclaimers
will let me move on to a first slide
completely irrelevant slide for this
audience where and trying to explain
what open source is I don't have to
explain this to the audience I believe I
suspect that everybody knows that there
are two basic types of open-source
licenses permissive and cut the left is
that does everybody know the difference
no who knows the difference between
permissive licenses and copyleft
licenses ah I should talk about it it's
because it's fascinating so mmm so
generally speaking open source software
is understood as a software
where when you get the software you also
get the source code ah together with the
source code you get a license that
allows you to modify the source code
that's what open source is but then
there is a second issue and you're also
allowed to share whatever you did you
modify that you created a new program
perhaps you take this one you can share
it that's also part of being open source
you can modify you can share but then
there's a question when you do share
this software by the way sharing doesn't
mean you share it for free your are
perfectly in your right to take an
open-source software may be modified a
little bit and then sell it to someone
that's allowed that's fine that's
allowed by any type of open-source
license so ah the restriction that comes
however there is a licensing issue with
permissive license you can do whatever
you want you can take the software
product and then you can modify it you
can sell it to someone else and you can
sell it to someone else with whatever
license you please that's why it's
permission do what do as you wish do is
you please the other type of a license
is copyleft copyleft is quite different
and quite brilliant i have to say again
you're allowed to modify and share and
sharing doesn't mean sharing for free
you can sell it to someone but su share
or sell that software you have to give
it to the new person to the person to
whom you're selling with exactly the
same license with which you received it
you couldn't you're not allow to change
the license and that means that that
person who would get your software lets
software from you that that person would
have a legal right to sell that software
or to give it away for free to everybody
in the world so as you can see there is
a tremendous difference because
basically you can take an open source
product with the permissive license
build a commercial product based on that
and profit from that commercial product
if you take software with a copyleft
license you can build a product based on
that but once you start
selling that product you have to allow
your users to give away that product for
free or to sell that product to
everybody in the universe which
basically makes it impossible to make to
sell it for a high price right so
because if your prices at all high
people would start undercutting your
even given giving it away for free to
everybody in the world studies mean
selling for money let's say somebody
takes the open source code and put term
I mean technique I did things in the
code which I advertising based then
would it be consider selling oh that's
an accent question and the answer is a
selling is not important here share you
are still allowed to search for money
it's fine ah so it would be considered
sharing and when you share you have to
preserve the license that's all so
you're more than welcome to take an open
source product to put a bunch of
advertisement into it and to start
giving it away to people or selling it
as you please but you have to preserve
the license so once I got it you have to
give it to me to the quad and I have to
have a right to a modified and B give it
away to the whole world for free I mean
makes it up the program today
functionally made the same but it looks
different yeah well that's that's always
true with got the left license you can
even sell it on those conditions that's
fine but people you have to allow people
to distribute and modify it and ah not
the permissive ones with capital left so
so by the way as we will see later
assuming we will get to the history part
that copyleft license was a truly
brilliant invention that played a very
important role in development of open
source software
so let me give you a little bit of a
summary of how incredibly important open
source software is today and sort of
given this audience I probably don't
have to convince you that open source is
very important on the other hand given
that I'm in the Microsoft right now
maybe I do have to convince you that
open source is in fact very commercially
important today so a staggering quantity
of open-source software so for example
one can do absolutely fine relying
exclusively on open-source products from
operating system to browser to office to
statistical software to development
tools and in fact my quarter happened to
be one of those people who over the last
three years use only one non open source
program and that happened to be adobe
flash that is free everything else that
he used is open source and he doesn't
seem deprived so that's kind of
interesting because getting around in a
wheelchair do everything that's true
that is true but there's a difference
because I him and many other people like
him don't feel particularly deprived
right so for example if you were to
limit yourself to say our open source
music well there's not that much around
not that much of open source music
around us and what is there is very
amateurish rights all the sort of best
stuff is not really open source so in
fact what's interesting is that free
software is high quality so oftentimes
we think of free stuff as kind of a this
is tough for poor people right so people
who couldn't afford so do people who
couldn't afford the real deal they they
they go with free alternatives and that
might be the case in many instances open
source is not it so in fact open source
software is quite high quality the
competition of open source and
proprietary software is largely not on
price this is what's quite interesting I
when I started writing this paper I
thought that this was about price about
money but it's not at all the case so
for
example are many users of Linux are not
only made the decision and are not only
quite off London could easily afford
windows big in fact they paid for
windows and they deleted it and
installed linux operating system also
Mozilla Firefox and Internet Explorer's
are competing with each other my zeal is
open source Internet Explorer is not and
both of them are free and the atmosphere
is doing very well so again this is
clearly not an instance of price
competition so in fact also an
interesting observation is that the most
that use of open source by individuals
is in fact the tip of the iceberg
compared to use of open source by
corporations as you will see two bullet
points later it is ah really the
corporation the way wealthy corporations
and not the individual users who are
relying most heavily on open source and
that again suggests that it is really
not about price it is about something
else so for example let me give it just
couple of examples ah that illustrates
an incredibly important open sources the
world largest supercomputer IBM Road
Runner and the world largest database
our own are based on open source
software so what software have you
ah that is a an excellent question and
to that question I have to confess I
don't know the answer I I have a source
that we quote in the paper and my
co-author who is much more program more
than I am could could give you much more
precise a precise an answer to that so
so if you want to know the precise
answer drop me an email and i will i'll
get you a precise answer but i believe
it goes beyond the operating system i
think serve the whole serve there so i
presume this so i am guessing that Road
Runner is probably not a single CPU but
a huge huge huge collection of boxes so
I would be guessing that basically the
program that allows those boxes to work
together than that part must be open
source that would be my guess but I I
couldn't name the and I presume the
operating system probably also the Linux
about I could given that it's IBM i'm
sure the operating system would be linux
goodbye yogi debate available uh-huh i
mean if you modify it and you don't
distribute it you Circle it open source
also there's a very good question I know
if you are so different types of
open-source licenses but generally
speaking with so the internet created a
sort of new type of usage of open source
software because now a lot of software
is used by creating value for the user
without that you're giving the software
to the user by providing a service and
that's the business that Yahoo isn't
that the business is facebook in myspace
Google we're on that business where are
they are not software companies and Sons
that we are not selling any software to
the user user doesn't see any of our
software but we're providing services
you found it
among the way to circumvent the coconut
license by kind of not really giving the
software but intense you're getting
around this oh well I so actually I
don't think that those can be
circumvented copyleft license I think
that was actually original intent of
Kabul aces because the original intent
of open-source licenses was that you are
take open source software and then you
use it for a business for your purposes
for doing whatever you want to
accomplish and in the process you modify
it in a way that I useful for you for
doing the job that you want to get done
and then you're not required to make it
available to others so this is not a
part of open-source license to make it
available for us and that was the intent
that was not a that's a feature not a
bug however you may choose to make it
available to others and in fact if you
would look at surf yahoo and google and
myspace strategy in this space some
myspace is still baby in this space but
if you look at the auckland google yahoo
is a google and many other internet and
IBM for sure a very heavy users of open
source and a lot of things that are done
by those companies with open source stay
with those companies you take up on
source you improve it you don't share to
the public but a lot of this is shared
so if you look at the list of
contributors to open source you would
also see IBM and Google and Yahoo and
redhead it doesn't mean that everything
is shared but a lot is and some isn't
and I don't know the quantities right
and that's how it was in Temple intended
i believe is near when one could be
featured at the people i took an
open-source modified it integrated the
binary
one situation is awkward binary on let's
say you are is computed for him to use
and another way you use binary I let you
all use my own computer remotely to you
the MIT why one would be a bargain it
that would be a teacher but won't be
allowed in another not ah so the point
is I I think we disagree with the
indenture the copy of didn't envision a
scenario where people could use the
software without without having it and
so I think it is about so uh so I didn't
buy anything computer so I mean I think
to some extent this is a bit of a
philosophical question but there's
there's an answer to this question and
the answer is a new couple of license
the new license that basically says well
are not only you have to share the
source code are in case you share the
software but even if you provide a
service over the net using that software
you still have to share the code that
license have been developed I believe I
and it's very unpopular it is not being
widely used and part of the reason is
out this google for example in the Alpha
very active contributors to open source
ah and as far as I know none of the
internet companies are wish to either
use or contribute to software on those
terms and yet that perfectly willing to
see a 2 to both use and contribute open
source software with a different license
so that seemed to suggest that in some
way from the mental level given that we
see that sort of open source is really
flourishing on those terms but not with
otherwise and stuff that that seem to
suggest that i'm not saying that that
new I that other licensed is somehow
wrong or evil I'm just saying that both
have room in the universe and at least
for now that the current one is
succeeding quite quite nicely
mathematician so that's why I did what I
don't understand what the meaning of
giving mind if I take a body and burn it
on your hardware and then send that
hardware will do excellent question and
I can answer the answer is ah and in
fact I so the short answer is you could
not do it if you take a binary and it
burn it on the hardware together with
that piece of hardware you gotta give
the source how do I know that well I
know that because one of the most common
our internet forms called I think
linksys that's I think when pretty much
dominant one of the dominant players in
this space and of course there's those
ones are the way the way of the future
have one of those in my office and 10
years from now or even five years from
now probably every corporate office
would only have internet phones right so
this is very kind of everyday technology
so that company built that internet
phone and I think its dominant player in
that more in the space they build that
phone using Linux operating system and
that operating system happened to be
happened to be a copyleft Linux is cut
the left so then they started
distributing those phones very
prosperous company as far as I can tell
and they were brought to court is it
look you are distributing the software
you're distributing the binary but
without the source code you are in
violation of Linux license and the court
said well that is correct and the
argument was software is often
distributed together with hardware for
example I
so you see now you know that I should be
right now at the daily marketplace sync
up but I'm not sir so yeah outlook
respects my privacy sir so the reasoning
of the court was well let's say I take a
piece of hardware floppy drive and I put
a binder in there I give you that
software on the floor p surely it's very
well established a precedent that if I
give you a software on the floor p in a
binary form now you have to also give me
a source code upon request so so ed but
if I find it on the phone and I don't
make it easy to read find anything I'm
not actually giving you binding where
was I was I was I was arguing they was a
perfectly good argument but it's subtle
they lost so learning from this lesson
when Apple decided to develop iphone
they also didn't go out writing an
operating system from scratch but they
went this are better with Berkeley
standard distribution eunuchs which
happened to have a permissive license
because i believe it was developed
before cut the left was invented i'm
guessing yeah so well couple left was
invented a long time ago but i believe
that that was the timing so so I phone
has a proprietary operating system that
is based on our open source software
with the permissive license on the other
hand Android the google phone is action
open source operating system based on
linux so in fact that serve our i think
as far as i can tell received wisdom
that linux a superior to the berkeley
standard distribution eunuchs which is
by now kind of a bit outdated and I I
would be guessing that the only reason
why Apple
opted for that was that they wanted to
keep the operating system proprietary
but I'm not sure maybe the way other
considered technical considerations so
yeah let's slide this taking
tremendously longer than I expected by
the way so at the time slows down the
speeds up depends how you look at it so
a couple of other kind of data points
most computer languages open source and
that includes some of the most are
popular languages so Java and Python and
Java is probably the most popular
computer language in the world my
compilers are open source so
interestingly enough they started very
differently I think a java was
originally sons proprietary language it
was not open source and then son opened
it up completely opened it up and they
were actually gradually opening up more
and more and more unlimitedly completely
open it up and they opened it up while
they were still the most popular
language in the world and I think they
opened it up because they were so
feeling the pressure they were afraid
that Python or some other language would
come from behind and over take over take
their standard and they want and they
felt that sort of make it open source
would make it more appealing so it was a
defensive move move move as far as i can
tell i'm guessing right good nose and
that's interesting because the story
played itself Fortran and COBOL that's
how IBM was opening Fortran back when in
the 50s maybe early 60s so the history
has a tendency to repeat itself so it's
interesting that if you look at
compilers and computer languages
essentially almost all of them are open
source so that some exceptions for
example C has a section microsoft casa I
think see i'm not sure but she has some
proprietary compilers but it's a but but
also plenty of open source alternatives
but essentially almost everything like
in a nine out of ten top language will
probably open source you will get
computer games nothing is open source
all the popular computer games are
proprietary so in fact that's not true
there's thousands of open source
computer games it's just none of them
are successful so this is quite striking
I pretty much all the successful
programming language is very few
exceptions and are open source and none
of the games are so there must be some
reason why it is this way and what this
paper is about what this paper asks is
first of all why is open source so
successful because surface an economist
I could see lots of reasons why it
shouldn't be successful so I wanted to
see some reasons why it should be and
second why the success one some places
but not in others so a couple of others
or observations about open source open
source completely dominates web serving
and I know Microsoft is a player in web
serving but of course Microsoft has much
smaller market share that Apache servers
so all the big internet companies are
using open source solution for observing
and but Microsoft has still considerable
market share their but certainly much
more than open source overall and also
infrastructure of Internet companies
Amazon Facebook Google Yahoo many many
other smaller ones is incredibly heavily
based on open source right so we see
that in certain areas open source
completely dominates and in certain
areas it's almost non-existent yes so
the google makes you know ninety-five
percent of their money from search right
right their search engine is not open
source right i mean i can't get there I
can't get their proprietary code this
way they do page rank okay so I mean
it's nice of them to you know have all
this open source
source code except for what makes the
ninety-five percent of their money Oh
horizontal I'm not my getting five
percent open source and ninety-five
percent close I'm not making any value
judgments here I'm not saying that you
know Google and Yahoo horn ice and some
other companies and a second technically
no but I'm all the relief netflix runs
on littles if it doesn't let everyone
see what their ranking everything
precisely is always so I you are
thinking do I think you'll become
positive life you are thinking of them
to come back no I'm not thinking them as
I'm thinking they're not the pad and
yeah to claim the glue I kind of open
source and successful because google
music I think is wrong because we're
google makes their mind which is all in
the search that's not open source so so
let's look at what the company where the
company makes its money and then save it
for that code that that pushes that the
money maker right well so the key word
here the key word here is infrastructure
right so I'm not saying that what they
create that that are they're sharing
everything with the world of course not
what I'm saying is that sort of the key
enabling our input for their technology
is open source I'm not saying I'm not
saying that it does you any good no it's
okay yo I think you know their key
technologies are paid ranking algorithm
and that's not all consumers so I am
every muscle infrastructure level right
so the operating system that that no cuz
I don't sell it that's what I'm saying
SE users so you can think of Google L in
two ways right you can think of Google
as a company that provides a service
that creates value ah and so let's let's
forget google let's say we are talking
about chevron motor come a chevron oil
shale oil right so she'll is not in the
software business and in the oil
business right but they also happen to
be a computer user so if you would find
out that sort of most of the software
that they use
is open-source you say or shall happen
to be a heavy user of open source right
that's not where they make the money
they make the money in oil but you would
agree that if they ran operating system
of the computers there right now the
database is based on operating system
station you say all thou shalt clearly
quite is a heavy user of open source
they also an oil company what I'm saying
here all I'm saying here is that all
those guys are very heavy users of open
source and that open source is critical
for the success I'm not saying that
they're sharing any of the any of the
benefits that's really good okay
certainly afford to buy windows licenses
and I wouldn't even affect their bottom
ah that's exactly the key point so why
don't leave it so that's exactly the key
point so none of those companies are
poor in fact I reach and usually when
you are sort of in the business that's
winner take all you take the inputs you
know the cost kind of you take the
inputs that would make it the best
possible product right that's what you
want to be want to win in the
marketplace and then you just negotiate
with the supplier by the right price
right so if someone has something that
works better for you you just figure out
a deal hopefully if possible and you
would use that so so it's striking and
interesting that does all those
companies are opting not to go with
commercial product that opting to go
with open source have you look at other
things that they buy you know they're
not that cheap you know they buy aeron
chairs so so why is it that they choose
to use open-source inputs they're right
so that is the key point here why opens
why do they choose to be consumers of
open source right companies started out
okay that's what the other point I mean
why does Google use you know linux
absurd maintain themselves right as
opposed to fine wares which we were
maintained for the question is when they
become so successful in region whether
that's that's point did it make sense
for them to switch the Italian not the
one man it's not an insurer sighs yeah
because when you are little then there's
even more reason if you are little
you're trying to succeed so you know
Google doesn't build their own chairs
and when they were little when they were
poor start up they just went out bondage
aeron chairs for six hundred bucks
apiece why well because when you try to
make great software you need good chairs
for the butts of your programmers and
Aaron does the job and it's fine so so
you would think that you know certainly
in the interests of Microsoft to get
startups hooked on Microsoft Technology
so so surely they ought to be a possible
deal between startup and proprietary and
vendor we're on you know you would use
our software you know for the first time
T we start making mine you don't have to
pay us or something like that you can
configure it out but that's not the
route they went so why is that nobody is
going that route and in the internet
startup feel so why is that so that's
what this paper is about so so let me
answer flesh out what are the questions
that I'm going to try to address here so
economies thought and wrote a lot about
open source ah so in fact including
Microsoft chief economist Susan a
thorough the world open source and and
most of the issues that economists are
concerned about what are the incentives
to contribute to open source and I
wouldn't talk much about this ah this is
not the question that we are going to
address and in fact to some except this
is definitely not a question why people
contribute up and so there are lots of
good reasons including just for fun
that's how founder of Linux called his
his memoir and so by the way if just for
fun where the real answer then you would
expect it would be lots of successful
open source of you computer games and
there are lots of open source computer
games not a future successful so the
real questions we are trying to address
is wise open source dominate some
important sectors of the software nest
and not the others so that's what we are
about here and so it's not that
surprising that people contribute to
open source right people do engage in a
lot of activities for finite people
create music for fun but how much you
know you don't see paramount picture
pictures taking some amateur song that's
of available copyright free
and making it in the soundtrack of the
movie right so all the but yet you
sister software companies doing internet
companies doing exactly that with the
software so why why is it happening
right so it's a bonus question so
Stallman who's i think richard stallman
basically the founder of open source
movement he talked to his so this is a
bonus question why did salman what did
salman meant when he asked his
supporters to think of free as free
speech and not free beer when thinking
about free software so assuming that i
will not run out time and i'm sure i
will i will give the answer to this
question otherwise you have to read the
paper so now let me sort of proceed so
there's no really model in the paper no
sense that we don't have formulas or
anything of this kind but let me serve
give you the fundamental assumption that
kind of drives a lot of things that are
happening in this paper so one
observation which is kind of obvious is
that one fundamental difference so one
obvious difference between open sores
and bind and the proprietary software is
the price but there's one more
difference open source software is very
highly modifiable by definition you can
take it you can modify it if you know
how binary software is impossible to
modify so if you take the same program
in binary or open source form in some
sense open source without regard to
price is an a superior technology its
superior in the sense that gives user
certain user sophisticated user lots of
options that proprietary software
doesn't give that user and that gives us
a key why it so happened that it is the
most sophisticated and wealthiest users
who opted for open source those are the
guys who really value that flexibility
but that's going to be only the
beginning of the story not the whole
story so so you can see that sort of
this intrinsic superiority of having the
source but it doesn't have to be
open if you think about it right so
there's no reason why sharing the source
with the user should mean making that a
source open in the sense of open source
software I can share my source with you
but give you a license where you're not
allowed to share it with other people
you have to pay me additional royalties
if you make modifications and blah blah
blah right so we could imagine those
kinds of licensing agreements they're
very rare it has been tried there are
some precedent so that there are some
companies that do that but the reason
that it is very difficult as contractual
costs become extraordinary high for a
lot of reasons it's just too easy to
cheat too hard to monitor too hard to
agree on things so as a first order
approximation we can assume that giving
a user recorded this is leave this
technological restriction that once you
share the cord you have to make it free
legally it's not quite the case you can
write a contract that says it's not
you're not allowed to do lots of things
we live but it's so expensive to enforce
in court that in most cases it's just
not worth it also it expose both sides
to legal risk I may be very hesitant to
touch your cord if I have to sign a
paper that I'm not allowed to do lots of
things because later you can bring me to
court accusing me of lots of things and
charging me for all and suing me for all
I'm worth and that happened in the past
so so there are real concerns there so I
will assume and that's not true its
first order approximation that giving
user code is isomorphic to just making
it open source product which is not
entirely true in practice their counter
example but they're few and far between
so that's the key observation that would
be driving my story and I believe in my
heart that if it were possible to write
and enforce contracts along those lines
where I can say look I'll give you this
cord but we have a complete contract
that's totally reasonable that would
govern or our behavior with regard to
the squad for okay future contingencies
and you know it could cheaply and easily
be enforced then that would be wouldn't
be open source software because then ah
you know we'll just agree on a
reasonable price on oil gets a very nice
proprietary product from you and just
pay a reasonable
and so I think from the mentally this is
the technological restriction the legal
so lack of legal feasibility of
enforcement that created the open source
movement and I think this is a
fundamental reason why Internet
companies do not want to touch
proprietary software so I'll illustrate
it so see turns so due to the fact that
users can sort of modified software it
also creates a lot of additional
efficiencies right user doesn't have to
communicate his needs to the to the
vendor right so if I'm sophisticated
user I want to change something if I
couldn't change it but on the vendor
could then this is costly process of me
communicating those needs to vendor
hoping the vendor would make a
modification then presumably vendor
wouldn't do it for free for me I have to
negotiate the price with the vendor and
that's the key variable the vendor might
potentially hold me up right even though
modification may be very easy since I'm
already so invested in this product and
you know what Sam google so it's very
important for me to modify your product
in a certain way and it's not that hard
to modify it but you know let's say that
product happen to come from a vendor who
realizes that hey this client makes a
lot of money it desperately needs this
modification even though I can make this
modification for a million dollars i
will charge billion because the client
is in such bad need of this modification
so that's a classic hold up a client has
this flourishing business that
critically depend on this piece and I
could exploit this client later on and
there's no way we can sign a contract
before that prevent this kind of
exploitation that's what the condom is
called hold up so hold up arises from
lack of contracture from infeasibility
of Sir full contracting for the future
contingencies so let me give you an
example that it looks and this is
basically the key insight of this paper
the way I see it so let me give you sort
of a
description of what women are here again
so so let's say buyer of software
product a makes a complementary specific
investment by developing complementary
software which is product be let
investment could be training or could be
creating other software right so you
have an internet startup they take some
softwares base for the infrastructure
but then around did they write lots of
other things they create this whole
service so that investment that product
that they created could be tremendously
more valuable than the software that
goes into the foundation of that company
so however I so basically the value of B
the investment complimentary to a could
be much much more valuable than a itself
however I if I'm it may be necessary to
modify product a in order to read
benefit from product B from that big
investment so for example you have an
internet startup they started something
out it's going well now suddenly they're
growing and in order to scale their the
product they need to change something in
product a but they couldn't because
proprietary right so that would be a big
problem for them they would have to go
back to the vendor and so on and so
forth and unless they have X lantus
signed the contract with the vendor web
render so I'll modify everything at a
reasonable price how do you find
wonderful reasonable price it's
impossible right the vendor would say oh
well you're such a successful company
just pass an arm and a leg for those
modifications so that would put uh that
internet company in a position where
they would be afraid to invest into
other software that complimentary with
the software able proprietary software
and that is what driving them to use
open source that's the reason for holdup
problem so in other words clearly with
open source software that would be under
investment in the developing who wants
to create open source right and it
couldn't make money on it so it does
under develop but this internet company
may choose an open source solution even
if inferior even these under investment
into that product because if they should
prepare
software they would be afraid to invest
in the complementary technology and now
they can go all out and invest in
complementary technology and in the
meantime keep building that that product
that the open source foundation of the
product they also may choose to share
the medications they make and the reason
that they would choose to share
modifications that they make is that
they may hope that other people would
yet improve that bottom layer of the
infrastructure they would benefit from
other people's modifications so they may
be direct incentive to share this some
of the medication that you make to open
source products that you use so so in
other words because of hold up buyers of
proprietary software under-investing
complementary products and if you make
big investments in the complementary
products it makes a lot of sense to rely
on open source solutions so let me give
you my favorite example and i love that
example because not software is hardware
so there's a company called i think it's
called arduino software or hardware and
basically this is an open source
hardware product small company based in
italy i start up i think the sales are
about 50,000 chips it may make chips and
those chips are all specifications
everything is open source you can
download it you can buy those chips from
anybody else right you can just take
those specifications send them to any
other vendor and get those chips from
someone else without paying a penny to
this company so this company makes money
by selling those chips but they are make
it possible for anybody else to compete
with them they have essentially no IP
when they develop IP they immediately
make it open source so why are they
doing it at a crazy well I clearly not
crazy because it's pretty impressive for
start-up from Italy to actually sell
50,000 units what are they doing so
here's my theory of what they are doing
uh who buys those chips why would you
buy a cheap so they originally developed
the chip because it was part of some um
I parked on some toy or an art someone
I'm actually not not sure what what what
I originally used but it could be used
for toys it could be used for art
projects that could be used for
it's so it's quite a flexible cheap so
think about it let's say you're a
designer and you're trying to design
something maybe a toy maybe something
else and you're hoping you'd kind of
strike it rich right you're hoping to
sell millions of units you probably
wouldn't you'll probably make one unit
and just for so you are investing a lot
into designing this new thing so if you
are designing something around the
proprietary cheap once you become
successful and you start it and you
start putting orders for like two
hundred thousand chips the chip lender
first of all might not even be able to
provide those chips reigns well we don't
have capacity to builders or they can
say I got plenty of capacity you know
they are in tow but you know we can
charge you an arm and a leg so and if
it's a small company then you're
particularly afraid that you know I'm
the first big customer I'm trying to buy
two hundred thousand chips because I
built a blockbuster toy but based on the
cheap well they would immediately just
take me for a ride write the 0 for two
hundred thousand ships the price would
be very high so so people would never go
with the cheap from a small company that
is proprietary because they would be
afraid that once they invested
everything in product development and
design the actually wouldn't be able to
get those chips at a reasonable price so
since those chips are open-source this
company pretty much granted that they
would never take advantage of people who
developed technology based on the chips
because the technology is open source so
that and that's I think pretty much the
business model so also there's an
incentive to share innovations because
once I develop something based on this
chip I may want to modify this chip I
may choose to share those I may choose
to share those modifications with the
public why well because maybe I'm hoping
that the new version of the chip would
be better yet and would be not just my
modifications but other modifications if
I am sato maker i'm not very concerned
about competition
earlier as I had actually accepted it
but not when I will my mathematics heart
it looks incomplete in the sense then
considered the service you are
developing it could be a client-side
service could be some software runs of
window there could be several side
service for example search and both are
I mean it's it's entirely possible
that's a cougar to use windows and
create its infrastructure but you will
take okay but yet they I need to make it
more efficient but the same thing would
hold if you write a client-side software
on windows which you may want to tweak
vendors to become more efficient so the
dependency on the underlying layer is is
the same I mean Google can pretty much
could have run its entire I'd I search
service on windows so it would be about
the same that we should it would give
the source little but why did the need
to do because you people get source who
writes application on Windows they don't
get so long enough I revisited how
important is I mean you got a citibank
right you know their quants very happy
with the performance of Windows gives
them and their interests in Frizzle they
don't have lots of you know OS and
computer scientists and their building
so they would have to create a whole
division but that's it my five on it
that's a subjective argument because I'm
writing about the pub windows I know I
think might be critical for me to access
good well a bit of those for you and you
can afford the OS guy right but you need
to hire an OS no no no but I'm Ramirez
are you done with you 25 windows it
might be critical for me to modify
windows to make my browser the best
browser my boy and his argument is
its acronym for you and I would like for
linux that the new is that you would
hire an OS guy get linux yeah but people
night rouse it for me because the
performances in that port yeah that's
what I'm think why in some cases
performance is more important and it's
not I mean it just funny that's exactly
the nature of the PM is nature the
application Ryan listen Sonny that's
another model Akane people already knew
browser because they believe performance
in the party leaders it's the features
right it's the features is the
interconnectivity the native of the road
roswell google chrome and one of the
things you're shouting it via pass via
pass they're fast they're not they're
not saying that they are feature
articles i modified Lomax are they going
to write the browser for linux they are
writing for windows so it's the same
argument that the dependency the
mathematics those are not like so
remember remember remember so they did
write the brow browser for Windows but
so remember i'm not claiming that the
paper that I wrote explain everything
under the Sun right so obviously their
windows computers and there are also
applications windows and I'm not saying
that it shouldn't exist or doesn't exist
of course it does so then they're like
this intro to their infrastructure they
said this is like a product yeah the
hand of Megan maybe there is nobody
likes you are making a difference
between that infrastructure is um in
both cases it's not infrastructure which
is important to google it is their
ability to serve searches if they have
some magical Oracle the wits of searches
and they could have built infrastructure
on windows they therefore even if you
some searches same thing is it is by the
adobe time politic is to read the PDF
file and so here essential service the
put both potentially the Pinot Noir so
where are some is revenge it out there
in for the performance of Windows not
have yeah okay and then get I go down so
then there stop right they either put up
with the bad you know
save me poor performance or or they go
out they use Lennox and they modify the
otherwise in order to provide
performance 19 so also i don't think so
i think the key issue here it's not that
it's just poor performance a good
performance I think part of the issue is
that are they some let's say there's
some kind of bug you realize there's a
problem and you just need to fix
something and if you're a super user and
you know how my subscale about it and
say look I realize that is some problem
with this operating system we have to
open the hood fix it up and the problem
will be gone so if you are using linux
on you and that's what you see Google
doing right there they massively
modifying linux and contributing to to
linux by the way and i would be guessing
that what happens is that they're doing
something that I realized this one thing
in little is that doesn't work quite
well ah and they fix it and it's
probably a lot of it is just bug fixing
and again you want to if you're a super
user you want to have that control if
your citibank you don't right so i have
probably what like two minutes left zero
minutes left minus two so i give me a
minus to plus minus 2 is equal to let's
say somewhere around in the neighborhood
of 0 so i need like two more minutes so
let me dwell on history for like exactly
two minutes so and hopefully it would be
intriguing enough that you'd actually go
out and read the history part of the
paper I promise it's actually the most
interesting part of the paper it really
is and it's short it's like before going
to sleep so open source is much older
than open source so in fact the practice
of the practice of developing software
is public good predates proprietary
software by over the decade even though
the term open source is relatively new
it's like less than 25 years old if I
closer than 20 years old the practice of
public software where you get the source
and you can do whatever you want to sooo
true open source is actually very very
old and predate proprietary software in
1952 IBM entered computer market they
were the second mover they were within
the year of the frost and turn a less
than a year so at that time the world
software didn't yet exist so obviously
the world opens up to
I didn't exist either but software did
exist and at that time the software
comes for free with the hardware and it
is open sourcing undo whatever you want
with it so interestingly at that time
the amount of money so this is like this
fake belief that expenditures on
Hardware exploded ah in recent years
that doesn't seem to be true so at that
time when thrust computers were launched
in the 50s the buyers of those computers
would spend as much more on software as
they were spending on hardware and IBM
was very aware with except that you
wouldn't be buying her software you'd be
having a staff of programmers who are
creating this software but that is an
expenditure and software which was huge
it was the same order of magnitude
however expenditures so I didn't realize
that and I wanted to increase
efficiencies and we need more software
is incredibly expensive to develop the
users at that time were super users I
mean ah you know who should it be to be
one of the like first five people in the
first companies in the world to buy a
computer right so those were really
super users and lowering the cost of
programming was of course very important
for IBM it is cheaper software is this
available software people would be
willing to pay more for hardware so IBM
wanted to encourage sharing of software
so guess what within the first year of
the lunch of IBM first computer they
created IBM share a community of IBM
users at that time the number of users
you can sort of count on two hands for
each system that was a separate commute
separate share the time there was only
one system so those within the first
year they create this IBM share they get
together they share software before IBM
create share those guys are already
sharing even without a beam facilitation
but IBM institutionalized and here's
what's interesting and very insightful I
think so so two dozen organizations from
members of share for IBM 704 and at that
time those people they already
understand
name of the game they understand that
sharing is its own reward so you think
surface an economist I think oh you know
who would want to create software who
would want to share in all sit on my
hands I'll try to sell no that's not the
name of the game so the contemporaries
right that we shared it in the next
slide so the eyewitness accounts is that
the real problem was not who would want
to share the real problem was everybody
was for shoving the software at the
throat of the other guy and the reason
is that those guys even though the word
network effect wasn't invented the other
1955 they already understood it very
clearly they understood that by getting
you to use my software and I already
developed a bunch of funds for
infrastructure complimentary to the
software right I was in this game for
six months if you would start using my
software you would obviously start
improving it for your purposes because
you'd like run into lots of problems and
then you'd share it with me of course so
I would directly benefit from you using
my software so they were shaving their
software into each other's throats and
according to greenville United Aircraft
browbeat share into accepting the
assembly threatening to leave the group
if another proposal is accepted right so
that is the early days of open-source
software so institutions of soft open
source software completely fascinated
fascinating three dates are open source
software by several DK by several
decades and they evolved in most
interesting ways ah thank you
it was trying to shout these papers down
everybody else well I think I think the
analogy is quite quite appropriate so
for a quite appropriate because I think
the reason that Salman felt that sort of
free software as in free speech rather
than free beer I think that's exactly
what he meant right when you write a
paper your paper is in some sense not at
all open source but in some sense it is
so to technology of science is a little
different from technology of programming
but I think the way Stallman saw it he
saw a software as kind of expression of
human intellectual activity and output
of that and he wanted other people to be
able to build on that to be able to
create new stuff from that and the price
wasn't that worried him he would have
been probably fine if you know there is
a reasonable system of payments there
but he didn't see how it would be
possible to have a reasonable system of
payments but that's exactly what worried
him it was like proprietary science
versus open science the science based on
which other people could build and he
felt that it's imperative for the human
endeavor for people to be able to build
based on the software that came before
them and that's why computer programmers
feel very strongly and emotionally about
open source even though hey they're not
the ones who go paying the price of
software they're happy when software is
expensive and the users like like me
don't feel passionate about open source
at all uh they they don't see moral
issue there even though the users should
be very happy about open source k isn't
it free but the users who don't care
programmers do and that's why it's free
speech because the program is free
speech but from you for users it's free
beer thank you